she's anchor megyn kelly
she's so interesting to me I was excited
to do this she's primetime now she's got
a big special that airs tonight on Fox
now we all remember how Donald Trump
attacked her after the debate last
August exactly so I wonder how was it to
sit down with him face to face first
moment awkwardness at all yes absolutely
when I went to get into Trump Tower that
day I was a little anxious I didn't know
whether he would try to embarrass me or
threaten me or berate me but he did none
of those things like or not you got to
respect megyn kelly for standing up for
herself in the face of this megyn kelly
is a lightweight I don't think she's
very good I think she's highly overrated
I have great respect for you that you
were able to call me and say let's get
together and let's talk to me I would
not have done that it was almost like
when a little boy likes a little girl
and like pulls her pigtails or you know
treats are bad so I cut my hair off
didn't kind of blow your mind that so
much was made over your haircut it was
so funny I was doing the profile for
Vanity Fair at the time and it was
wrapped and the reporter we had to have
a follow-up interview about that year if
she called me back and said I need to
know why you cut your hair and I said
because it was long and I wanted it
short some are calling her the next
Oprah or Barbara Walters especially with
her primetime special tonight but all
politics aside Hollywood's taking notice
of the 45 year old happily married
mother of three I didn't get an invite
to the Met Gala I don't know it came I
was like really I feel a little
ridiculous I do you know posing on the
red carpet
I was like yeah VOC coming don't it was
amazing I I met Taylor Swift as I was
walking him who's awesome
so I shake her hand and she sees me and
she says oh wow megyn kelly powerful
woman good for you so nice to me and I'm
like you too good